[Music]
enslaved groom news slave run groom
submitted by I have no life men are
being tricked into arranged marriages
and then traffic to work as servants and
laborers that sounds like a fun job
that's crazy I want to do that so is it
a billionaire sending out their
daughters to from a foreign country to
pretend like they need a green card and
then when they say yes know what you got
to come back and meet my family so it
could pass the green card test when that
guy goes to that country boom kidnap
like that not really
I'm pretty sure they're getting like
what is it sex traffic to write the
ladies no it's the guy guys I know but
the ladies are who are they getting
married to so this is happening there's
a lot of families in Hong Kong there are
a lot of families in Hong Kong yeah so
these families what they're doing is
that they're looking back in their home
country and they're looking for single
men that they have to support their
family but like their small family
they're not looking for men that have a
big family just like you know maybe like
a parent is one too oh sweet
yeah so they're looking for these men
that are really vulnerable that are
looking for a better life outside of
their country so these families they
Scout these guys out they tell them like
hey you know promise you this awesome
life and in this really exciting city
Hong Kong you know you can make a lot of
money you can send money back to your
family and you can support them from
abroad so then these men are getting
tricked into these marriages because
then these women they fly over to
Pakistan or India they marry them there
and then they process the whole like
green card situation and the passports
and everything and then these men go to
Hong Kong and once they're there the
families there start beating them
verbally abusing them forcing them to
work in construction it's like get out
yeah it is crazy so then like they hide
their passports and these men because
they're coming from countries
you know like being showing any sign of
weakness or anything like that is really
humiliating so they don't want to tell
authorities that they're being abused
and they're also scared of being
deported because they don't want to
leave it but that city so we're gonna
get paid though yeah well they do get
paid but the family takes all of the
money and then once they get home a lot
of these men have to after an entire day
working in the Sun and construction or
whatever they're doing once they get
home they get beaten to do a house work
too so they have to do chores at at home
who's doing the beating
it's either the wife or if it's not the
wife then we'll be the parents the
in-laws or like the siblings they've got
a gang of guys like just ready to beat
them up and a mom too
so like the brothers this seems like a
lot of work like like let's say five
guys gotta beat up Michael to do
construction right and then we gotta
beat up Michael to cook business it
seems easier the US v to do the
construction in US v cook ourselves
because they want a slave they wanna
relax get tired from [ __ ] beating
Michael up yet should they be put in all
this work or like beating breaking down
the man to the point where this man will
no longer have a voice for himself and
he will just serve the family well
technically you only work one day a week
if I'm beating him on Monday you're
beating him on Tuesday TIFF is beating
him on Wednesday so every day it's a
different you know you just work once a
week Michael is working seven days a
week paying the rent doing all this
stuff and you live like a king you just
have to work four times a month beating
up Michael this is the true story by the
way this is the true story I've seen it
Michael I know like it actually happens
to me all the time
shut up Michael you love your job cry
for help
Shh don't tell anyone guys why you guys
saying [ __ ] you guys are beating his ass
too
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
it's a pup this is Thursday it's
impossible why he's here I was forced to
come here today this is how you know he
doesn't get beat you see you never
flinch this is so sad because like in my
mind I was picturing oh here's a chance
to really like you know level up in life
marry into a rich family there's a hot
girl where'd you get the rich family
from okay
it's just a Cinderella dream but
reversed oh other people yeah it's like
hey no but no no eligible guy here for
my daughter anybody want to [ __ ] her if
I was single Hey
I just picture myself going over in a
g-string with cufflinks and a [ __ ]
bow tie only I'll do whatever and then
but then they're like oh but you know
you are the servant you have to [ __ ] my
daughter 24/7 you have to wash the
dishes you have to do this yet to do
that but at the same time I'm gonna give
you the Rolex watch Wow because you know
how long people they love name-brand so
how was it uncovered apparently this has
been happening for decades oh yeah yeah
it's just like this website like they
did like a whole expose on it and
they're just talking about how like
there are these NGOs that have been
trying to help these men get out of
these situations but it sucks because in
Hong Kong apparently they don't really
care they're just saying like alright
well these men can stay in Hong Kong as
long as they have a sponsor but if they
leave their wife and like that family
then they don't they no longer have a
sponsor so they no longer have a valid
visa and so now they're stuck with a lot
of undocumented men they're trying to
like that have escaped from these like
abusive homes in the abusive lifestyle
so it's just like a continuing problem
and they can't go back home oh well they
don't want to because it's like a
third-world country and they're trying
to make money to send back to their
family and it's also really humiliating
to go back home and admit all this [ __ ]
that I want it's like a failure yeah
yeah I don't think they could even
afford plane ticket cuz that's a lot of
money that sucks that's a predicament
it's like this is straight-up slavery
because they own these men because
they're saying like you know we brought
you it we paid for you to be here
you know we paid for your ticket your
plane ticket your passport your visa
everything we own you
so these women aren't just for hire and
they just go along get their kind of
whatever it just seems like it's these
these families that are all in on it
it's get out it is get out it's super
common apparently it's like a pretty
high percentage of the men that are
there that are enduring this I know what
I'm gonna do now business idea go to
Hong Kong look for all the Indian and
Pakistan guys gather them up create a
company called naan bread Inc start I
love garlic naan I'll start a garlic
naan factory because they know how to
make it really good right and I will
create a job for them and they could be
sending money back home and I'll pay
them regular Hong Kong wages you didn't
even come up with the business plan
though don't need one I built businesses
intuitively now that I've done so many
and I won't be handling it so it's okay
I know it's kind of you know how I know
it's gonna win I won't be doing any
other work and Indian in Pakistan who
are really smart so the business runs
itself exactly you just hire the right
people I've never seen an Indian kid or
Pakistan akela backwards I've only seen
like Indian kids do crazy good on
spelling bees yeah take a spell good and
it could engineer good
so maybe naan bread factory isn't the
best did you see the episode of remember
the Steve Harvey Show that we saw and he
was having a spelling bee be off I don't
know how he would say so we all felt a
spell off spell battle yeah those are
great words that she picked um so what
was that what was the word it was like a
20 letter word it was like
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious and
then as soon as so Steve Harvey's like
what the what is that he's like flipping
out and the kid you could tell he read
he knew on us but he's like
a little Indian kid he was like what
like seven eight years old and he
couldn't wait he was just like hey can
you use it in a sentence please and then
the girl said it and then he was like
okay and then he just started spelling
and it was perfect Indian kid so
geniuses that's so cool
it was just cute cuz he was like yeah
wait I haven't been a Hong Kong and so
long I remember like on every street
corner there was a Indian guy like
selling suits he was probably a slave
Joe you know though he owned the
business did he own the business I hope
so like they're different guys okay but
there's maybe it was like the suit
district but that was their thing you
know how like Cambodians have donut
shops Vietnamese have nail salons and
Koreans have liquor stores maybe it was
that part of town but yeah dude just be
in the corner like you settling you want
a suit you want a suit you want a suit I
almost got one but I was like Hong Kong
is too hot for a suit why are you
planning on wearing this suit in Hong
Kong yeah I wanted it look sorry I
wanted it look like pinstripes I was
like nobody knows me in Hong Kong you
just got in the shorts ring the fake
Rolly yeah but I went in there and I
just wanted to look at the shops and
what but basically I think it's like
really quick turnaround they they take
they tailor you do all that stuff real
fast the suits like real cheap and he
looked decent to it didn't look bad
they're known for making a really high
quality custom suits oh really
a lot of the dealers out here they
actually they take your measurements and
they just send it over there to Hong
Kong yeah because it's good Jesus good
and cheap so you do a good job and it's
cheap yeah and it doesn't look like bad
so yeah but I was cheap at the time too
little did they know you can't sell to
poor people yeah but these guys they're
slowly getting help in Hong Kong is how
come the official they're saying that
they're gonna be making changes to help
these guys but doesn't seem like they're
doing much we are too busy with a
kung-fu problem okay
did you guys enjoyed that episode of
just kitty news if you did please leave
a comment down below and share us your
thoughts and your feelings for more
episodes click right up here
[Music]